hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video so
in this video we're going to be working
with the ti-84 or the ti-83 it's similar
for both calculators and we're going to
talk about how to expand a binomial
using Pascal's triangle but actually
we're going to use the calculator
instead so what we're going to do since
we're here on the fifth power the fifth
row of Pascal's triangle which you
remember Pascal's triangle starts with 1
and then each row begins with 1 and then
you add the two terms above to get the
term below so you can see this is going
to be 1 1 2 okay so you're adding the
two terms above it okay 1 4 6 4 1 and
then 1 5 10 10 5 1 so this is the fifth
row here it starts off at at row zero
and what you can do instead of doing
that especially if you have a higher
power than 5 you can go to your
calculator go over here to y equals okay
in the upper left hand corner then go
down here to math and we're going to
arrow over to probability we want
combinations and we want 5 choose and
renews our variable key X ok so now
we're going to go to our table set
second table set that's right where the
window key is and we're going to start
at 0 we're going to go up by one's okay
so that's the Delta there and we're
going to just put it on auto and we're
going to go to second table over here in
the upper right hand corner and if you
can see 1 5 10 10 5 1 same values we got
over here using Pascal's triangle but
this is handy to use your calculator if
it's going to be a higher power maybe
like to the 10th through the 12th like
that you wouldn't necessarily want to
draw your Pascal's triangle all the way
down to the 12th row so just a little
bit of a shortcut there for you
so if you want to see the rest of this
I'll just show you a little bit more
about it if you go down here these are
your coefficients now so it's going to
be 1 5 10 10 5 and 1 and you're going to
take that first term ok remember this
was X plus 2 to the 5th and you're going
to have it go in descending order so the
first term X to the fifth then I go goes
down from there X to the fourth X cubed
x squared
X to the first X to the zero but
anything to zero power is one then you
take the second term positive two and
you're going ascending so it'd be 2 to
the 0 which is 1 2 to the first 2 to the
second 2 to the 3rd 2 to the 4th and 2
to the 5th and then in between each of
these terms are just added together
ok and then all you have to do is go
back and simplify each term and that's
going to be your expansion of X plus 2
to the 5th so I hope you learned
something from this video how to use
your calculator bit more effectively
I'll see you in the next video I'll talk
to you soon